Speaker 1: Donald Trump gave a very strange
interview to a guy named Joe Pags. I don't
know who Joe Pags is, but he really
likes Trump. And during this interview,
Donald Trump went back to the story of the
FBI, might have planted the documents to
frame me or they might have stolen documents.
Wait, the FBI planted or they stole? They
brought in or they took out. And if that's
the case, how did you know to telepathically
declassify the very documents that the
FBI planted? None of it makes any sense,
but Trump is back on this train once again.
Speaker 5: And they wouldn't let us have
lawyers there. They wouldn't let us
have any representation. So who knows
what was planted? Who knows what was put in
there? Who knows what was taken out? And,
you know, if you look at the group, it's largely
radical left run. Nora Right. And you look at.
Speaker 1: Us, it's all there, quite frankly,
communists, folks. This was generally speaking,
a really wild interview. Trump is doing very
minor shows by phone, not even taking the time
to get in front of a video camera. That's the
theme Desperation to be interviewed anywhere
that will have him. He's welcome on this
program any time, by the way. Let's listen
to a little bit more of this Joe Pags interview.
And you'll notice it's not exactly hard hitting.
Speaker 4: You're beyond very good. So I was
a television news anchor in Michigan for eight
years. I was on the streets as a reporter.
I know that state very well. They love you
there. And I'll never forget what you did in 2016
at about 3:00 in the morning in Grand Rapids,
and about 5000 people showed up to cheer
you on as you wanted to beat Hillary
Clinton. Why is Michigan so important to you?
Speaker 1: Yes. Tough question, by the way.
Speaker 5: Well, I just seem to have an affinity
for the state. I was given the Man of the Year
award, Joe. Years ago.
Speaker 1: That's a lie.
That's a lie. First question. First answer.
That's a lie. This is old ground. Trump has
repeatedly claimed that he won Michigan's Man
of the Year award. The award does not exist.
7 seconds in. Trump has already told a lie.
Speaker 5: 11 or 12 years ago, and I used to
tell them, Why are you countries
like Mexico to take your cars,
your automobile manufacturing business
away? And I don't know. I've always felt
that Mexicans just let so much get
away. It's got such assets and it
just let so much go to go away. I mean it.
Speaker 1: Anyway, so it's just lies and
lies and lies. Let's just jump, you know,
randomly into the middle of the interview
just to get a little bit more of the flavor.
Speaker 4: Mr. President, the only time we found
out anything that may or may not have been in Mar
a Lago was after they took it and started leaking
it out. So what do you think the game is here if.
Speaker 5: You know what?
Speaker 1: Hard hitting? No. Like,
why did you have the documents?
Speaker 5: It is very interesting.
Nobody ever heard any leaks or anything,
any problems. And then all of a sudden, when
they take it out and they put it into NARA
or wherever they have it, all of a sudden
things started leaking out of the documents.
Speaker 1: It's all leaking everywhere. So
a very strange interview riddled with lies
as usual. And the theme is nobody's even
having Trump on in terms of the serious
network. It's Joe Pags and Real America's voice
and right side broadcasting wild times. And just
imagine what's going to happen over the next
week as all of these different legal issues
come to a head. We'll take a quick break and
be back with Jesse Singer right after this.